hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to there's
some things we forget about some things
we don't know about and then some things
we forget about one of these things is
films as much as I talk about nostalgia
Camus V's good and bad there's still
some movies out there that are
overlooked whether we forget about them
or do even though they exist they're not
totally over logged or unheard of
they're just not looked at enough so
I've compiled a list of the top 11
greatest nostalgic American children's
films that many of us forget even
existed why top 11 because I like to go
and step beyond so sit back enjoy the
top 11 under and industry classics
number one the rescuers down under this
is one of the Disney animated films and
everybody forgets about it didn't have
any princesses fairytales and it was a
sequel to a very mediocre film let me
put a lot of effort into this providing
us with an all-around great adventure
but how do you remember the first
rescuers film and how exciting that was
she might catch us and her swamp mobile
will swipe it I've always wanted to
drive it riveting now take a look at the
sequel
damn this film is a serious upgrade with
some great animation great suspense and
it's a great underrated voice work
that's about new heart Ava Gabor ver
prising their roles from the first film
but it also has some really late greats
like the always incredible John Candy
and oh okay ones enough and the only sin
tense George C Scott I didn't make it
all the way through third grade for
nothing on top of it the Eagle scenes
are just phenomenal one of the few
on-screen moments that really simulates
the illusion of flight whoo it doesn't
make any sense how it takes place in
Australia and only two of the characters
an Australian accent but then again how
come in Beauty and the Beast only the
candlestick has a French accent and no
one else does I don't know either way
rescuers down under is fun thrilling and
sometimes even beautiful and considering
Disney sequels recently this one is one
of the few that's actually a million
times better than the original rescuers
down under definitely comes out on top
number 10
Tiny Toons how I spent my vacation even
though it never got a theatrical release
how I spent my vacation was a fully
animated hour-and-a-half movie time
together a dozen hilarious storylines
one deals with Buster and Babs heading
down the river another is about Elmyra
torturing a ton of innocent animals but
the best one involves plucky as he
travels with Hamptons family to the
Disney World knock off happy world what
result is the road trip from hell
everybody's been on this car right where
the family won't shut up tension is
riding and the only Escape is into your
own insanity they play great games like
spot the car pick up hitchhikers who
happen to be wanted psychotic killers
I hate duck and eat Classic meals like
Neal and cream cheese on white with a
crust cuddle fishes I won't ruin the
hilarious outcome of when they do
finally get the happy world land but
trust me when I say it's beyond
hilarious and of course it has all the
slapstick imagination and clever in
jokes and Tiny Toons was known for in
the later years this one is one of my
favorite satirizing the THX sound system
the audience is now there and just look
what they do the poor et with great
riding and top-notch animation how we
spent my vacation should have been
released in cinemas but oh well we'll
just have to settle for it on video if
you can find it definitely check it out
it's a wonderful dose of The Rocketeer
this is kind of like a Disney version of
Indiana Jones only not as a lot of downs
you may think it's got great action
great characters and great hot steaming
Jennifer Connelly's it's about a guy who
finds a rocket pack that can propel him
into the air and save people I'll do the
flames not for his ass I don't know
maybe it's a special kind of underwear
but it's still fun to watch the villain
is played by Timothy Dalton who plates
an Errol Flynn type celebrity who's
working for a pretty risky organization
I always knew Hollywood was run by Nazis
but wow he's out to get the rocket so
that the Nazis can partake in the most
unpractical takeover plan of all time
who needs planes when we can fly our own
non bulletproof bodies it's also got
some stars before they made it really
big like Alan Arkin Terry O'Quinn Holly
Sorvino and of course ginger - Jenny oh
you can roll my lab rat any day actually
the ironic thing is that the only guy
who didn't go anywhere was The Rocketeer
himself it's a shame because he's really
not that bad an actor he's like if
brendan fraiser was a likeable action
star it also has the best Howard Hughes
ever that Scorsese movie with Leonardo
DiCaprio dressed up like Halloween yeah
I don't buy that this is the guy who
should have played him I can totally see
him wearing tissue boxes in the future
overall Rocketeer was a great adventure
this guy was the real rocket
memory the Prince of Egypt even though I
love this movie I put it pretty low on
the list because the film actually was a
hit when it first came out but since
then nobody ever talks about it or
acknowledges it and to be honest it's a
very impressive piece some of this is
because a lot of people compared to the
Cecil B DeMille film the ten
commandments but the two are totally
different styles in this film
most of them ran disease don't just
declare their enemies their brothers
first or foreskin pride and destiny to
battle each other even though they want
nothing more than to just be a family
again
some people are thrown off by the songs
and the use of celebrities like Steve
Martin and Martin Short does that make a
Steve Martin short but the truth is
they're not in it for very long and the
songs themselves actually aren't half
bad especially considering that done by
the same guy who did wicked but most of
all this bill is epic
everything it does is huge from big
songs to big emotions to big eye
pleasing visuals even the acting is
pretty damn good
especially from ray Fiennes who plays a
chilling ramasees even though it did
well it's never regarded as anything
great but it truly is it really tries to
capture the human emotion of the story
and combine it with the sheer scope of
its biblical sighs it's not ten
commandments but it's not supposed to be
it's something different fresh and
friggin huge Prince of Egypt should not
only be acknowledged as its own creation
but certainly as a great one
namitha explores this film really
targets the imagination of young sci-fi
it's about three kids river phoenix
ethan hawke and some kid who never went
anywhere
we'll get signs and their dreams about a
spaceship that's trying to communicate
with them so what do they do build a
spaceship in their backyard of course
duh okay well that is a little bit out
there
explorers does know how to take a
relatively silly idea and actually make
it pretty plausible to kids most of the
movie is just showing them making the
ship including how it will fly how to
breathe and all sorts of other details
and when they actually do get to the
actual spaceship it's a pretty damn cool
spaceship with all sorts of monsters and
strange gadgets that they come across
the actual aliens themselves are kind of
gay which i guess is part of the joke
all they know about humans is what
they've seen on TV but that's a lot of
build up for a pretty silly punchline
there is a clever twist having to deal
with a quote-unquote space pirate that
comes aboard but again it seems like
kind of a weird turn for something else
being taken so seriously before then
again it's not as much about the payoff
as it is about the journey and explores
what's definitely a very very fun during
the film he was to say is definitely
worth again you know mercy
the Iron Giant this film is picking up
in popularity but it's still not a
household name like a lot of Disney
films which is I arrived because the
film's director went on to direct
Incredibles and ratatouille but this
still has a ton of creativity comedy and
heart it's about a kid who befriends a
gigantic robot alien and how he of
course wants to keep it a secret
unlucky Timo the alien can't quite fit
in his room which leads to a lot of
funny and clever moments the best thing
about this movie is the subtle
relationships everybody has not just the
kid in the alien but the kid with his
mother the kid with the agent the agent
with the commandeer the mother with the
artist all these relationships are
present but they're not shoved in your
face they play out very naturally of
course the Giant himself is pretty damn
cool too
he's made of metal eats junkyards and is
voiced by Vin Diesel buy me that for
more people are discovering this film
and with good reason it's a good film
ranging from subtle and kind to
outrageous an action-packed much like
the giant himself it's a load of fun and
very well-constructed
number 5 flight of the navigator this
movie has some of the best build-up
you'll ever see in a film it's gripping
curious and knows how to keep your
attention it's about a kid in 1978 who
trips and falls and somehow wakes up in
the year 1986 everything is aged except
him scientists are baffled but even more
baffled by the arrival of a spaceship
that looks like a metal wand they
believe that somehow the boy and the
ship are connected and that somehow the
boy is the only way to figure out how to
get inside the mystery and build up in
the first step is the best part of the
movie but much like explorers its it
comes to kid movies syndrome and has a
typical kids movie second half but even
the second half isn't bad watching a kid
fly around in his own personal spaceship
it's pretty cool and on top of that it
has Paul Reubens of pee-wee Herman Fame
who does the voice of the computer
information are required to complete my
mission that doesn't sound like peewee
whoa there is actually I'm glad he
doesn't do the Pee Wee boys that much in
this movie I mean can you imagine how
awkward that would be this is crack the
one downside to the movie is that the
kids a bit of a wimp I think it was
written with a younger boy in mind but
instead they went with this older kid
so the cry scenes are well kind of weird
please where's my mom and dad
dude just plug in your xbox and you'll
forget about all your problems like
everyone else your age with great
build-up great story and great effects
life and navigator is definitely worth
of rent sometime soon return to Oz oh
you have to see not to the wisdom behind
the charming colorful music oh why
I can't wait to visit that magical water
line again to see all the whimsical
enchantment
at least yet I mean talk about not being
in Kansas anymore Return to Oz was
nothing like the original 1939 musical
this sequel was dark with severed heads
shock therapy and these creepy little
demon monsters known as wheelers this
was one hell of a creepy creepy movie
and it was so damn cool I mean for as
creepy as it was it was still pretty
imaginative still keeping a lot of the
charm it's a real nature that oz had to
offer just don't expect any cute little
munchkins singing unless it decapitated
the film also has new characters like
tick-tock Pumpkinhead and a couch named
Gump like I said before I think a lot of
kids like being scared because it pulls
them much more into the action if they
didn't like being scared they won't go
out for Halloween or watch High School
Musical as dark and creepy as it is
Return to Oz what's fun and creative
knowing exactly how to scare the
enchanted shit out of us who's a novel
experience wasn't it oh babe pig in the
city this movie is just incredible when
you're not being sucked in by all the
imagination visuals and surprising
interesting characters you're sucked in
by the technical wizardry that makes
this movie work but it's funny because
not once do you question how they got
the animals be trained so well or how
they did so many of the effects how can
you when you have so much creativity
just exploding around the characters are
entertaining the story is fun and it's
tone ranges from white and fluffy to
dark and brooding everything is extreme
and odd the exact opposite of the first
date movie which I guess threw a lot of
people off nobody knew how to feel while
watching this film whether to sit and
cry or laugh uncomfortably but to me
that's the sign of a great film make you
feel and combine all sorts of emotions
to give you a new and bizarre feeling
like feeling happily sad this film is
literally a rollercoaster ride combining
big emotion with big visuals not to
mention one of the most fun climax of
July
see yeah it's a bit dark but your kids
could use a little tougher material
sometimes as long as it ultimately
results in a happy ending I think most
kids will be cool if you get a chance go
to your local video store and bring home
the pic go to Batman mask of a phantasm
fresh off the animated series Batman
actually did have one cartoon film that
was released in theaters this film came
out around the same time as Joel
Schumacher's Batman Forever and many of
us were surprised to find that the
animated film actually treated us more
like grown-ups than the grown-up film
the film dives into Bruce's past as we
discovered that he actually almost had a
normal life before becoming better and
as the cartoon usually did it pulled us
into the tough choices a gothic
storyline that Batman is best known for
on top of that we got a new villain
called a fantastic who could appear and
disappear with a puff of smoke that's
pretty cool and they were also nice not
to give us the Joker who plays a part in
a murder mystery that's actually pretty
detailed and interesting as always the
animated Batman is dark and epic mixing
the dreams of a hopeful life with the
darkness of reality it's funny because
everyone who sees this movie always asks
why Finn does Phil do well in theaters
to which I always reply well the juice
in the truth is the film was a big bomb
at the box office but hopefully it's
life on DVD is growing because it
actually is a very slick and
well-constructed thriller it's intense
adventurous and dripping in that
brooding gloom that we all love from
Batman if you missed on the big screen
the don't get your chance to catch it on
the small one and the number one
underrated is now to classic is secret
of MIT here's an anime a film that
really treated us like adults and is
actually more clever than once while it
was about cute little mice we're having
big adventures secret of NIMH had a
sophistication to it that very few
animated films have especially
considering the subject matter its hero
mrs. Brisby
it's not a wisecracking her own
but rather a frightened mother raised
her way through certainly danger to save
the life of her son her fear is our here
but her bravery gives us the courage to
stay with her and face the danger on top
of that the secret of NIMH is a
three-way battle between the evolution
of nature science and the unknown all
three are in constant battles with
resulting in extreme ideas and uncertain
decisions the rats of NIMH have been
altered through medical experiments and
have evolved into creatures that may be
even smarter than mankind creating
electricity light and even some mystical
elements that can't be explained because
of this the rats have a responsibility
to their gifts and decide what choices
must be made to survive and continue to
grow ultimately it's all three science
nature and the unknown that are needed
to move forward to a stronger future and
it is the heart of our main character
that shows them the way it's settings
are harsh and uninviting but it's mrs.
Brisby who pulls us through her warmth
and courage its ideas are complex but
not so much that kids and adults can't
follow it and understand it the secret
of NIMH is powerful and intense creating
a world of nature technology and magic
and it's in my opinion director Don
Bluth strongest work the secret of NIMH
my pick for the best underrated
nostalgic classic I'm going to saturate
I remember it so you don't have to
you